hello everyone uh welcome
back to the deep real workshop um thanks
to the simon's institute for continued
support
and to the speakers and audience for
joining us one hour
after that i see it i cleared that line
today we have a few exciting talks
around the topic of
uncertainty modeling in deep personal
learning
without further ado let's welcome the
first speaker scott nickim from ut
austin scott hong thanks
uh yeah so thanks everyone for having me
um so today i want to talk about
uh something that is a little bit
different of a format from what
most of the speakers this week did um
instead of
doing a deep dive into a piece of my
work i want to give a bit more of a high
level talk
on sort of a position piece and i'd like
to convince you that all
rl researchers should be interested in
what's going on in the safe learning
community right now
because it actually has something to say
about a lot of
interesting big open problems in
reinforcement learning
um so first just some definitions uh
people use safety in all sorts of ways
and so
uh as a word and what i mean when i say
safety is really correctness plus
confidence
so correctness meaning that we're
meeting or exceeding some measure of
performance which could be
you know anything from expected return
to not violating temporal logic
constraints
and we just want to have confidence that
we're meeting that correctness metric
which is either
you know formal verification or more
often a probabilistic guarantee
so this is a pretty broad definition of
safety that covers most of what people
mean when they use the word but probably
not
all of the different definitions
so in the reinforcement learning
community there have kind of been
two applications of ideas from safety
that have seen a lot of attention in the
in recent years
one is safe off policy policy evaluation
or ope
this is where we're trying to determine
a probabilistic lower bound on the
expected performance of a policy given
data generated from some other policy
so we might have you know a walk-in
controller for some robots
that doesn't fall over but is kind of
slow and we have some policy we think
might be faster but before we run it we
want to make sure it's not going to fall
over
or fall over more often for example
using historical data
a related problem is the safe policy
improvement problem
so you know you might be familiar with
rl learning curves that look like this
and safe policy improvement says well we
don't want performance to bounce around
we actually want to ensure that every
time we take a learning step
we're actually improving monotonically
with high confidence
and so often the way that this works is
there's like a policy proposal step
and then um you just run safe ope but
there
are various ways of doing this so
there's been a lot of progress in these
areas in recent years
but there's a common belief in the field
that these are
sort of inefficient um which is
generally true actually but
so you should only use them or care
about this work
when safety is absolutely necessary when
you know you're in a risky situation
where somebody could get hurt or you
could lose a lot of money or whatever
and otherwise this is just for like you
know those safe learning people
and i want to convince you that that's
not the case that safe learning is not
just a niche area
but it has something to say about rl
broadly
so why should all rl researchers care
about safe learning well
you know i think there's first the
obvious answer which is just that
many if not most real world cases
actually demand reliable learning
even if safety is not an issue nobody is
going to want to use
the methods we develop if they don't do
what they're supposed to
most of the time and can give confidence
so that's the obvious answer and i think
that actually alone is enough to say
that
everyone should be paying attention to
what's happening in safe learning right
now
but i think there's an even more
convincing case that's maybe less
obvious which is that
safe rl i think is a really strong tool
set that has something profound to say
about a lot of open problems in rl
and i'm going to very briefly cover a
lot of these kind of in rapid fire
today um including but certainly not
limited to
how should we define and learn from
reward functions in a way that we're not
going to sort of hack reward and do
something that is not what the human
intended
um you know how can we create rl
algorithms that are efficient and stable
this is a very general question
uh how should we use models in rl
especially when we know
they're incorrect what are good
exploration strategies which was you
know a topic of an entire
day's discussion this week how do we
discover representations that are good
for learning
these are all questions that are really
interesting to the broader rl community
that i think safe learning has something
to say about
so let's just jump right in so first
question
uh where should reward functions come
from and how can we prevent reward
hacking when rl agents are learning
um so i'm gonna be looking later in the
talk at a lot of work from the rest of
the community but
this is actually going to focus on a
piece of my work uh right
now so or my labs work i should say so
you know i'm interested in getting
robots into the home in the workplace
um and therefore i believe that end
users should be able to define
tasks that they want robust to perform
and even uh
experts are not very good at defining
rewards you know that are
descriptive of the task and can't be
hacked and so i really envision if we
want you know a very general system for
for specifying these tasks that
reward functions are generally going to
come from people sort of
in the form of one of two types of data
largely we're either going to see people
giving demonstrations
or we'll see people giving preferences
over behaviors or trajectories
or maybe critiques you could have
natural language and other things but i
think these are the two largest
you know most common modalities
and so the question is if we have data
in that form either
preferences critiques demonstrations how
do we
provide confident learning from that
such that we don't end up
hacking the reward function or in other
words
you know assuming that the person meant
something by these demonstrations or
preferences that they did not mean
and optimizing for the wrong thing and
so you could call this
safe imitation learning i think you can
also think about it as reinforcement
learning but just under reward
uncertainty
but in either case what you really want
to do is you don't know the ground truth
reward function you only have these
demonstrations and preferences
but you still want to be able to upper
bound the policy loss of the robot
versus the human expert with high
confidence
and this is hard because it's like a
really ugly version of the safe ope
problem it's just like ope except
or it's just like policy evaluation more
generally
but you don't know the reward function
you just have these demonstrations or
preferences
um so this is really tough and what we
really want to be able to do
is with high confidence after we've seen
this data
come back and say hey i think i figured
out a policy that i can guarantee with
high confidence is almost as good as you
most of the time
in other words i can bound this policy
loss you know with probability one minus
delta to be within epsilon
or i can't and i need more data a robot
that knows what it knows essentially
and you can think about this in terms of
safety but you can also think about it
in terms of reward hacking or value
alignment
not doing the thing that the person
really intended
okay so how can we do this well i don't
have time to go into great detail about
this but we just have this paper at icml
this year that we call bayesian rex
which stands for reward extrapolation
so it builds on some earlier work of
ours called t-rex which is
trajectory ranked reward extrapolation
where the basic idea is that it's a
inverse reinforcement learning or
imitation learning algorithm that
essentially takes in
a set of ranked demonstrations that are
ranked in order of how good they are
and what t-rex does is it tries to kind
of find a reward function that explains
the ranking
and can extrapolate and actually do
better than the best demonstration or
better than the human
it turns out this setup also makes it
extremely efficient much more so than
other state-of-the-art algorithms and it
performs significantly better than
things like bco and gale
what bayesian rex does though is that
t-rex just gives you a point estimate of
the reward function
and bayesian rex actually gives you a
full posterior distribution
and at a very high level the way it
works is that we first have a feature
pre-training set where we try to find
a feature extractor that is going to
give us um
some good features for later uh
performing mcmc to find different reward
functions that might fit the data
and we do that by training on the
original t-rex loss plus some auxiliary
losses
and after that what we do is we apply
that feature extractor to all these
ranked demonstrations
just once it's kind of like a
pre-computation step for the next part
that just gives us feature counts for
all the demonstrations
and what this is going to allow us to do
is perform mcmc really efficiently
we can just draw a weight vector um
from the the unit ball and uh
this is going to um represent a reward
function
and to judge its likelihood we're just
essentially going to take its dot
product with all of these
which is going to give us the expected
return that it would assign
to each trajectory and then we just want
to make sure
when we determine the likelihood of this
reward function does it respect the
ranking constraints
is it giving more expected return to the
higher ranked trajectories
and what this is going to allow us to do
is very quickly perform mcmc which will
eventually give us this this
distribution or this posterior over
reward functions
so then how do we use this posterior
well we take the demonstrations we run
bayesian rex to get the posterior
and then we have a really efficient way
of computing uh a policy loss
um that corresponds to each reward
function
ri that could have been true and what i
mean by that is the robot comes up with
some evaluation policy
maybe it's given it you know this
evaluation policy by someone that and
they just say
evaluate how safe you think this policy
is or it comes up with it on its own by
you know running rl
on the mean or the map reward function
in any case you have this evaluation
policy and for every reward function ri
that could have been true
you want to ask the question how well
are we going to do
under reward function ri compared to how
well the expert
does if ri is the true reward function
and what that's going to do is it's
going to give us this distribution of
policy losses
and we can take that that distribution
over policy losses
and we can use it to compute a measure
of risk that's often used in like the
finance community for example called
value at risk
so the for example the five percent
value at risk tells you
essentially how bad that fifth
percentile is
the the div the dividing line between
the 95 percent
best outcomes and the five percent worst
outcomes
and we're going to put a confidence
bound on this based on the amount of
data we've seen
and so what that allows us to do is the
the robot can basically say hey
given the data i've seen in this
evaluation policy
i can tell you that with high confidence
i'm almost as good as you most of the
time
um or i can't tell you that and i need
more data
and we have several papers that have
active learning ways of
collecting more data efficiently for
people as well
so that's the basic idea so what can we
do with this how can we reason about
uncertainty and prevent reward hacking
so this is a cool example uh from an
atari game called beam rider and it also
showcases this method really scales up
to
difficult high dimensional problems so
beam rider is an interesting game
because if you don't push any buttons at
the beginning of the game
what happens is that it just kind of
sits on this this opening screen and
things move around a little bit
but you uh it never progresses past the
screen and you can't die and the
simulator just runs until
it times out um and
we use this to our advantage to show a
nice little thing about risk so what we
do is we give it some demonstrations
uh we you know learn this uh we infer
this posterior over reward functions
and then we ask our system to uh
rank in order of how good it thinks they
are five handcrafted policies
a b c and d which are just better and
better in increasing order from from a
to d
and we can see that with their their
mean score over here plus a no op policy
that never hits any buttons at all
and obviously is bad because it will
never get past score zero
so here's the interesting thing if we
just take the mean or the map reward
actually just a point estimate
which is what most algorithms you know
would infer
it gets the ranking of a through d
correct but it actually gets the no up
policy wrong it thinks no ops really
good
and it's because this reward function
actually kind of grabs on to a very
simple explanation of why some
trajectories are better than others
it just thinks living a long time is
good so it gives a constant reward to
all time steps
and we see reward hacking happen right
it thinks the no op policy is really
good and so the noaa policy is hacking
that reward
but if we look at the five percent value
at risk instead
it gets a through d right but it thinks
no op is really risky
um which it is there are a lot of reward
functions under which doing nothing
would would be very bad and so by
considering risk
we're actually you know reasoning about
this domain better
and you can think about it in terms of
risk and safety but you can think about
it in terms of reward hacking as well
and this is not just restricted to this
policy evaluation case we have a new
uh paper at nurips where we show that we
can also do this in a policy learning
setting where we can actually
we have a nice convex optimization
strategy to learn a policy
that takes this posterior and then that
learns to balance
expected return and conditional value at
risk in a
uh in a principled way
okay so that's the first question i
wanted to address you know
of all the cool things safer l can do
for for reinforced learning can do for
reinforcement learning
one of them is that we can uh figure out
how to
infer uh rewards that are difficult to
hack
and we actually do what people want us
to do okay
so second question you know i talked
about how a lot of people ignore safe
learning research because they just
think it's slow and only for when you
know things are actually really
dangerous and risky
but i want to ask the question can safe
rl actually be
more efficient than standard
reinforcement learning
so how would that be possible well let's
consider the true costs of rl
so when you're doing rl you know you're
you're typically doing all these things
to get it to work you're doing lots of
hyper parameter tuning
for every set of hyper parameters you're
trying out you have to run them a bunch
of times because you have high variance
in the runs
you have a good run that can get killed
by a performance crash
um and i think this brings up a lot of
questions about our practice
like why do we think we should why
standard practice usually to learn from
scratch
every time you try a different hyper
parameter set um why do we tolerate
performance bouncing and crashing in rl
and more generally why aren't there good
black box algorithms yet where we don't
have to tinker with all this
and i think safe learning has something
to say about this perhaps
so there's this cool paper from shimon
whiteson's group last year at nureps
it's this algorithm called hoof and to
vastly oversimplify what they're doing
they essentially at every learning step
uh generate a bunch of candidate hyper
parameters
take a learning step with those hyper
parameters to get a bunch of new
policies
they use historical data to do ope to
evaluate each of those
and then more or less they're taking the
one that looks best and so this allows
them to do hyper parameter tuning online
um which is useful because you're not
starting over every time and they're
during different phases of learning you
might need different hyper parameters
to make good learning progress so one
question i have
and that this is still an open question
i don't know the answer to you is
what if you combine an idea like this
with actual
high confidence ope checks so that you
get monotonic improvement with high
confidence
and or more diverse or more intelligent
proposal mechanisms
um do we get something that starts to
address
these issues where we have hyper
parameter tuning happening online
we don't have these performance crashes
we lower the variance in our runs
and we get toward a more black box rl
solution
we've been playing around with this in
my lab and predictably it's difficult
but i think this is a really promising
area where safe learning ideas
can really strongly impact general
practice
sort of across how we think about
general rl algorithms
okay next question how should we use
models in rl
especially when we know they're
imperfect um
safe learning certainly has a lot to say
about this i mean people think about
uncertainty all the time with models
but i think there's one sometimes kind
of overlooked way of doing this
that has come out of the safe learning
literature that i just want to highlight
and it comes from this idea of the
doubly robust estimator so if you're
trying to do ope
and you're using important sampling one
thing you can do is you take your
your unbiased estimator like per
decision important sampling
and what you can do is you can subtract
something from it called a control
variant
that is computed using a model and
essentially the way you can think about
what a control variant is
is every time you get a sample which is
like you know a sample from your
important sampling estimator
of what the the expected return is the
uh control variant is giving you a hint
as to kind of which direction the mean
is in and how far away it is
um and this correction or this hint is
zero mean so it's not going to add any
bias to your estimator
but if your model is good enough that
you're computing the control variant
with
you're going to lower the variance of
your estimator
um and so this is really cool it's a way
of using the model
in a way that is not going to bias your
estimates even if it's wrong
but if the model is good it's going to
lower your variance and we had a paper
from a couple years ago that combines
this idea with statistical bootstrapping
so
we use bootstrapping to generate a whole
bunch of models that we know are wrong
use them as control variants and use
them all together in an ensemble
to generate high confidence
confidence intervals around our ope
estimates
that are unbiased
okay another question exploration you
know this is something that was a topic
of a whole session this week
how can exploration best leverage domain
knowledge and uncertainty
and you know what does safe learning
have to say about this
so we have this paper from a couple
years ago that introduces this really
simple idea called shielding
this is actually the first thing i'm
talking about today that's not
probabilistic although it can be made
probabilistic
it kind of comes from ideas from the
formal verification literature the
formal methods
literature and the idea is that you're
given
you're going to use domain knowledge you
have to write down some temporal logic
constraints
that you don't want to be violated ever
and you're going to write this down
rather than in like the complex
uh input space of the domain you're
going to write it down in like a highly
abstracted state space again
you know using your knowledge of the of
the domain
and we have you know there's an
automated way to turn this
into sort of an automaton that describes
the safety conditions
and we can use this to essentially
generate a family of parameterized
policies
um that by design can never
violate this constraint and we use this
as what's called a shield
to make sure essentially that the uh the
agent is never going to take an action
that is going to uh irrevocably you know
definitely lead to failure
at some point you know so going 60 miles
per hour when you're still only 10 feet
away from a brick wall or something
so this is a nice way of injecting
domain knowledge
it's certainly related to safety but it
also has this interesting exploration
effect so if you look at this graph here
red no shielding green shielding we see
that learning is just faster because
unsurprisingly exploration is better
we're using domain knowledge
to inject this and it's not doing stupid
things when it's exploring
it's not doing things that are obviously
bad and so you get better exploration
and to do this we had to make a lot of
you know simplifying assumptions
and we're injecting a very strong form
of knowledge but you can imagine
a lot of this knowledge coming from
transfer for example
or there's a new paper that just came
out this week from some of my colleagues
at ut
austin where they're doing this in a
deep learning setting
where they take deep neural network
policies
project them back down into like one of
these safe families
via imitation learning and some other
tricks
uh and do their their learning updates
you know to to make sure they're
constrained in this safe family using a
shielding idea
so again i think this is a cool little
place where ideas from safe learning can
have something
important to say about a topic like
exploration
and finally just very briefly what can
safe learning say about discovering
representations that are good for
learning
so you know mark and colleagues you know
introduced a distributional rl a few
years ago
and it wasn't really posed as a safe
learning method but it does reason about
uncertainty essentially or distributions
over uh return
and in a follow-up paper claire who
spoke earlier this week and mark and
pablo
found that again to sort of oversimplify
one of their discoveries
that it does distribution rl does not
help and can even hurt in tabular
environments um it's only in the sort of
function approximation case that it
seems to help and when you're using a
deep neural network
it seems like it's really a good
auxiliary task basically and that it has
a regularizing effect and helps you find
good features
and i suspect that the same is true
generally for
these methods from the safe learning
literature that are considering
uncertainty
and in fact that there might even be
deeper connections i think between safe
learning and representation discovery
especially making sure that when you're
thinking about the tales of
distributions like reward functions that
could be true
you might have to consider features that
you just would have not considered when
you're thinking about point estimates
okay so that's my whirlwind of different
topics um
you know and i hope that this is food
for thought at least
that safe learning is not just some
niche topic
but it's something that all rl
researchers should be concerned about
for two big reasons one
just as i mentioned that many real world
cases actually do demand if not
safe at least reliable learning so that
people want to use these algorithms
but also because safe learning is just a
really strong tool set
to address all these open problems that
the
the entire field cares about like reward
hackability exploration
uh stable and efficient and fast rl um
and so the next time you see a safe
learning paper uh i hope you don't pass
it over and actually think about you
know what might this have to say about
the problems that i care about
um so that's it thank you i'm happy to
take questions
thank you very much scott uh this is
fantastic this is a really neat work uh
let's open it for questions
i have a question sure hi martha
hi um you sort of seem to making a case
for
if we have good algorithms then we might
actually have safe algorithms at least
there's sort of a connection there in
our the key
the rl community should presumably be
wanting to work on good algorithm
good algorithms that's sort of what i've
been concluding too because
you do look at individual learning
curves and you have to think to yourself
how is this what my algorithm is doing
like this isn't learning at all you know
on average across runs is learning but
within a run it's just
absolute garbage so that's clearly not
acceptable um so i guess maybe the
question here is when is that not the
same you know what if we're talking
about robust algorithms we clearly need
robust algorithms for safe rl
we need robust algorithms for and let's
call it regular rl
where where are the two fields like
where should the two fields be different
i guess my feeling is they shouldn't be
different i i think
and that's kind of you know maybe
provocatively and jokingly why i called
the talk you know is safe learning the
future of rl because
i think that you know as a field we've
kind of been optimizing for the wrong
thing
uh for a long time which is just this
you know average performance across runs
and what we really want are these
reliable algorithms and in fact that if
we have reliable algorithms i think that
we're also
just going to see those those average
curves uh likely
you know go up too um and so once we
start thinking about the right metrics i
i hope to see
almost a full merger sort of of those so
off the top of my head i'm not sure if
if there are huge differences i mean i
think maybe one difference would be that
um
when you just care about sort of average
case performance and you want to make it
better but still use ideas from safety
uh you're probably more comp you have
more of an appetite for risk and you're
more comfortable
even using heuristic kinds of methods
and so
even as a weak example i mean trpo uh
it is inspired by the safe literature
certainly i mean it's built on
i think it was like picade's you know
theory of monotonic improvement
but you can't actually compute the
things you need to compute so it uses
uh you know approximations and it
doesn't actually improve monotonically
but
for a while you know at least it was it
was showing improvements over
other algorithms
i thought the idea of doing um off but
first of all very nice talk
um i thought the idea of doing uh off
policy evaluation to help with
hyperparameter tuning was really
interesting um
could you tell us a little bit more
about what your lab is doing in that
direction
yeah so to be clear i mean the the who
fork i was talking about is from shimon
whiteson's group
um yeah so what we've been trying to do
is come up with
various types of proposal mechanisms
maybe other than just like
using different hyper parameters so
we've been looking at like
um trying to come up directly with
uh policy proposals that would be easy
to evaluate
based on the historical data we have and
also thinking about
how to use historical data um in a way
that's not gonna
create like a multiple uh hypothesis
testing problem and things like that
and actually there's this whole
literature um from
especially some people carnegie mellon
i'm forgetting the names right now but
yeah
on um it's called uh
oh now i'm gonna forget what it's called
uh sequential confidence or sequential
bounds
um where you actually can reuse some of
this data in a principled way
so we've been thinking about things like
that to come up with more intelligent
proposal mechanisms and then using
actual safety checks to try to get
monotonic improvement and stable
learning
um but it's really hard for a lot of
reasons i mean
you know i was trying to say like oh
safe learning is is not necessarily
inefficient but it is
it's just that you know we're hoping
that when you take into account
like the whole ecosystem of costs of
doing rl and practice
that we can get some savings by doing
this and just get confidence and
stability
um but it is tricky to get working and
we we don't have kind of a working
solution for this yet but
i'd be shocked if there there isn't
something
there so
can i jump in
uh so i'd like to follow up marta's
question
about relationship between safe rl and
ariel
without any safety considerations
um i guess there there has to be
some inevitable trade-offs uh that you
can prove
that if you want to be safe then you
have to give up on performance and
whatnot
so it's not like that uh because from
your talk and
from what you were saying it like i got
the impression that
you kind of think that like safety is
for
free and like you need to do it anyways
so we should all just do it and then
uh safety makes everything better it
makes
some things better and maybe that's the
real objective that you care about but
if you cared about the other objective
which was just you know maximize reward
uh then maybe you can't have both
uh at the same level right yeah you're
absolutely right
um so like our new work that we just
posted
archive a few days ago but the one i
mentioned was just accepted at nureps on
um
sort of a convex optimization strategy
for balancing
expectation and uh or expected return
and
uh conditional value at risk there's
there's absolutely a trade off there and
you can even you know we kind of plot
the um the efficiency curve you know
that shows
how like the pareto front essentially
for how you can trade off between these
objectives
so in that sense yes i think there's
absolutely a trade-off
um in in the more broad sense
i mean i think um
there are a lot of ideas from safe
learning
that can just make rl better in general
that don't involve trade-offs so like
for example the one i talked about
uh with using um using models for
example so if you want to you know bring
in a model
don't add bias uh just you know toss it
in as a control variant essentially
you know this is an idea that kind of
comes at least partially from the safe
learning literature
it doesn't necessarily lead to a
quote-unquote safe method that's doing
risk minimization or anything
and so i think my argument there is just
that there are at least ideas that come
out of the safe learning community
that can uh improve rl across the board
but you're right that there's absolutely
trade-offs between risk and expected
performance
okay yeah great thanks can i ask one
more question maybe i can see it's
time but um you you made the statement
that
these methods are inefficient do you
mean that they're sample efficient or
can you just tell me actually more what
you mean specifically that they are
inefficient
yeah so i meant sample inefficient so i
mean um you know i didn't have the slide
in here but i often like to
poke fun at phil thomas since i work
with him a lot and
uh you know he has these like graphs and
like some of his papers where you know
they're doing opu and what i would
consider like a fairly simple problem
and i actually i guess amazon some of
these too
so sorry i'm gonna poke fun at you for a
minute too you know and and the x-axis
is in like tens of millions of samples
and so you know to get these guarantees
it's sometimes pretty hard and if you
want to do monotonic improvement i mean
you do have to ask the question
is your op going to be so expensive that
you should have just spent that time
doing all these different runs with
different hyper parameters and
restarting when you crash and
um so so i think there is a question
there but you know
my bias maybe just because of what i'm
interested in but is that
we can do better by going going the high
confidence route
um maybe emma should get a chance to
defend herself though
let's do that and then we'll switch to
the next step um i think
i think a lot of them are very
inefficient i think one of the big
challenges in off-pull like in batch
reinforcement learning is how do we
substantially reduce the sample
complexity and um
i think it's been a really exciting like
last five six years in that field
the last two years and so i think some
of the model based stuff recently
i think we've been seeing sort of you
know what rather than trevor bringing up
we've seen someone that
some approaches that are empirically um
very good with pretty small amounts of
data but don't really give you
confidence in the resulting solutions
and then some other ones which are less
data efficient
but do and so i know my hope and i think
many others is to kind of
continue to close those two gaps so we
can get to the best of both worlds
yeah agreed all right well thanks
everyone